kollegah ist der technisch beste rapper
der welt das sagt nasa jetzt im
community video und er meint wirklich
der welt nicht ganz so hohe meinung hat
er von deutschen rap videos die findet
er nämlich ziemlich nicht so toll also
er macht seine er selbst und findet die
deutlich besser jetzt community video
best of show hat geschrieben jetzt mal
ganz im ernst
denkst du nicht dass deine professionell
gemachten videos von seiner eigentlichen
leistung als rapper ablenken imac 27
möchte wissen was hat dich dazu gebracht
nasa films zu eröffnen
und was oder wer steckt hinter nasa ames
ramon stefan und ich was mich dazu
gebracht hat war einfach sehr schlechte
video deutsche rapper wo ich einfach
immer klappt gut wir können es besser
gerhard fragt was hältst du vom heiraten
als abba also sehr hart meinte ist was
schon mal davon halten ist glaube ich
eine lebensaufgabe die jedermann haben
sollte und ich denke dass auch rapper
heiraten sollen und dürfen und des ok
sollen sie es tun
maly musik fragt was hältst du von
kollegah und kannst du dir ein feature
mit ihm vorstellen
kollege finde ich auch rap technisch
glaube ich überhaupt zu dieses punchline
ding ich hab das auch mal so ein
bisschen verfolgt was er genau tut und
ich denke dass kollege mit seiner
technik definitiv bestimmt einen der
besten rapper der welt ist also ich
gerne auch keinen army rapper der diese
vergleiche so hinbekommt wie er
musikalisch spitze aber glaube ich auch
nicht zusammenpassen jona sah mich wird
einfach mal interessieren was du von den
harmloseren deutschen rappern wie zb
gestern kro s ja und damit grüße nach
österreich also habe ich das halbe
hinterwirth oder gesprochen caspar crew
sind haudegen wie die böhsen onkelz das
ist die frage die im community video mit
den beiden an sie gestellt wird wenn
euch das interessiert schaut euch dieses
video an
oder möchte der wissen ob leute lieber
entertainer oder vorbild sein möchte
dann schaut euch das community video von
ihm an und jetzt lasse ich etwas zeit
das habe ich nämlich bisher nicht
gemacht dass wurde kritisiert jetzt also
etwas zeit um auf eines dieser beiden
videos zu klicken achtung